hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour or
so then we'll see what's making the
headlines
with catherine osler former editor of
tatler
author two of a new book the duchess
countess
and with the former bbc royal
correspondent
jenny bond great to see both of you to
the front pages then first of all
before we get your thoughts dominated of
course by the news of the death
of prince philip my strength and stay
that is the headline
on the front page of the times repeating
the queen's tribute
to the prince on their golden wedding
anniversary back in 1997.
this is the front of the daily mail then
the headline
farewell my beloved
a similar headline for the mirror
goodbye my beloved
the sun has a special wraparound
two-page cover
with the words we're all weeping with
you mom
the daily telegraph fills its front page
with a picture
of the prince and leaves the words for
its inside pages
similar to for the guardian
the daily express reflects on the
prince's life of devotion to queen and
country
with the headline deep sorrow
the i2 calls are reflecting on what it
calls
a life of duty
while the star describes him simply as
her rock the press and journal
also uses the word rock reflecting on
the fact that the princess duke of
edinburgh
was particularly loved in scotland
and though the financial times doesn't
lead with the prince's death it does
carry a front-page picture of him
well i'm joined then by catherine osler
and jenny bond where to start
catherine an extraordinary life a long
life
many newspapers of course reflecting on
the devotion
of the queen and prince philip as a
couple tonight and
her majesty's loss yes um
well i was very struck by that male
cover i think it's very
clever you see two things in it you've
got
him in his you know his star his order
of the garter
all his medals and her and her tiara and
her wonderful
jewelry looking so regal and yet the way
she looks at him
is just so sort of loving and personal i
really think you get both sides
of their life in that one picture
jenny what about you i mean we saw very
similar with the the daily mirror as
well didn't we this
this extraordinary bond these two people
had how they complemented each other
despite being very different the
different roles they had
and certainly the newspapers showing the
couple
do reflect on that yes i think that's a
lovely picture yes and the mirror also
has a lovely picture
um with a similar headline good goodbye
my beloved
they were a fabulous couple together
that
he was such a counter point to her um
she
is quite a shy woman by nature and yet
he was so
self-reliant so full of confidence
and i saw them um at many events
obviously over very very many years
and when a royal tour i tell you can be
quite fatigue and
quite tiring even if you're just a
reporter covering it
so much more so for the principals um
and perhaps when
she might find it be finding it very
exhausting
um even a little tedious there i say he
would he would lighten the mood he would
get someone in the crowd
chatting or he'd pick up a little girl
and bring her to the queen
so she'd give her posie um he was he was
opposite to her in very many ways but my
goodness what a partnership they had and
the papers reflect that today
absolutely we're watching other pictures
too of that i mean the sun
does what the newspaper industry calls a
wrap around the complete cover all the
pages inside as well
with that sentiment we're all weeping
with you mom
he's just been there all our lives
hasn't he katherine it's
it you know he is an institution himself
as part of the monarchy but
also is that the fixture in our lives
and our sensibilities
isn't he i mean born you know when lloyd
george was prime minister it's an
amazing he is sort of to us he sort of
eats british history but
the sun i particularly like the rap i
particularly love seeing the wedding
picture there where you it's so
sort of romantic and sort of lovely
isn't it and you
it's very easy to forget they had a
whole life before
she became queen you know there they are
she's a princess
he's in the navy um when my my uncle was
in
uh was the high commissioner in malta
and they went
on a visit there and he told my aunt
they'd never been as happy
as they were in malta which is before
she became queen
between you know there's that i think
it's a five-year gap between
wedding and coronation and there you
have it
very cleverly in there
and jenny i mean that was such a
significant phase of their lives wasn't
it the early death of the queen's father
while they were on a commonwealth trip
to to kenya
um and the significance of course for
prince philip was that he gave up his
naval career
something that was so important to him
and something which he had done so well
at
um predominantly during the second world
war um notably did well and many people
say he could have got on to be
first sea lord you know it must have
been a great sacrifice for him at that
point
it was yes indeed he was mentioned in
dispatches for his war record
um very very valiant war record but
he he was asked whether he regretted
that i'm sure it was one of the greatest
regrets of his life that he had to give
up his naval career
but in typical uh form he said well
regret
what is the point what's the point of
regretting anything i mean
it happened so you just get on with it
don't you and i think
um today the eye newspaper reflects
that sentiment very well on its front
page because it says
um a life of duty and that is
what he buckled down to do um and did it
with a plan that has to be said he he
said that
my my first and only duty now on is to
support and serve the queen
and that's exactly what he did and also
in the eye there's a piece by harry
mount which is mentioned on that front
page
in which it says his blunt manner was
his greatest
pr tool and in many ways you know i
think
it was because he he said what he
thought
sometimes it turned out to be a bit
tactless and hence we got all the
stories about his gaps
um but he was direct in a manner that i
think people
really appreciated and people look
forward to
reading about him to seeing him and
deleting him because
um you know he kind of shoot from the
hip and uh i think people like that
yes harry right nice picture catherine
interesting because this was
his final formal um
bit of service if you like saying
goodbye to the royal marines having been
their captain for
64 years this was the summer of 2017
when he formally retired not many people
retire at the age of
96 do they i mean that that is a life of
service and devotion
and duty which is something that both
the queen and prince philip shared as
a common commitment yes is it isn't
isn't he
incredible there i mean i i
look at these pictures and i keep
thinking about
his childhood and how terrible it was
you know the father who ran off the
mother who
was sent to hospital uh when he was only
very young for five years he didn't
speak to her for five years
and then his favorite sister died in a
plane crash
and he sort of dropped into sort of
gordenstein quite
alone and i think it's very fashionable
now to talk about building resilience in
our children
but that's what circumstance forced on
him
something that he sought to share with
the children of britain in the duke of
edinburgh's award scheme
was which was his way of trying to give
other children what he'd had which is
the relief that comes from action
and physical activity i think that was
his way
of overcoming difficulties and he knew
this would work for other people
so marvelous to see him keeping going
then when he was so old but i think he
also knew
that was what was good for him
yes this fractured childhood was
replaced really by the structure that
you get from the military
but they're structured to jenny from the
royal family if we take a look at the
times too
my strength and stay the words of of the
queen
just a thought on on her tonight in the
building behind me here at windsor
castle
without the man she'd been married to
for 73 years been with him for longer
than that obviously
your thoughts um for her and about her
tonight well yes of course i think
the whole nation feels for the queen
tonight um such a very
long uh stable and happy marriage
um her partner her companion the only
man that she could confide in the only
person the queen really could tell it as
it was to
and he was the only person who would uh
tell the queen off if he felt like it
and say well
that's a stupid remark in private he
would say that
she was very clever in that she allowed
him
to run the royal estates to be the head
of the family
in public obviously he had to defer to
her to
um though he viewed it as a very equal
and balanced partnership
um i think the only comfort one and
think of for the queen tonight is that
she has been able to share
most of this last year with him uh
because of the pandemic they've been
um hold up together at windsor castle um
and except when he was in hospital they
were very much together
which is a little different to um the
prior years
um after his retirement he went to
sandringham and spent a great deal of
time at wood farm which is
a smaller house there um while the queen
carried on her work
in london and lived at [ __ ] palace in
windsor so they were apart quite a lot
but she has the comfort of knowing she
has spent
most of his last year with him together
yes i mean a strange benefit of the
pandemic that these two
you know or the queen very busy still at
least prince philip in the past
um had been so busy they had shared less
time with each other
and the times just a final thought
catherine um is one of the papers we can
read where they start to reflect about
the
funeral arrangements um to be held here
and the question of who might be there
with the covert restrictions
and whether prince harry will will fly
in your presumption is that he will
i would have thought he would um
i mean he has to doesn't he
and certainly the time speculates that
that he will come
and uh possibly uh megan will not
because uh she is obviously quite
heavily pregnant so but uh
we are way more detailed certainly from
the palace about those
funeral arrangements plenty more about
uh prince
philip too sorry catherine carry on
i was just going to say it would be it
would be extraordinary if you didn't
okay well well no doubt we will find out
more details but plenty more still to
come as well
reflecting about the prince's life of
service to queen and country
with the mirror
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now catherine
osler
former editor of tatler author of a new
book the duchess countess
and the former bbc royal correspondent
jenny bond welcome back to both of you
um jenny let's delve straight inside the
paper shall we inside the
daily mirror which as many of the
newspapers do have
multiple papers or pages rather uh in
in the newspapers for tomorrow but a
really poignant one once again alone
after 73 years of love and
certainly giles brown ruth i heard on
the radio today saying that she'd
watched them after an engagement where
they'd been separated
they got in the car to drive home
together and he was clearly regaling a
story to the queen who was chuckling
for a good 15 minutes they must have had
a most amazing
partnership together um a romantic
relationship and this and this great
partnership in work too
yes yes he certainly could make the
queen giggle and laugh a lot and that
sometimes she really needed that
yes the mirror i think has has a
quotation there from the former private
secretary the
late lord chartres uh he served the
queen for many years
um and and others before um and he was
part of the old guard the old guard who
probably viewed this
incomer with some suspicion this
modernizer this
this as the queen's cousin once put it
to me this foreign interloper who just
probably wanted to
run away with the goodies he probably
viewed the in that
in that way but he came to appreciate
all that prince philip meant to the
queen
and the quotation in the mirror is that
he treats the queen simply
as another human being and she really
values that
and i think tonight more than ever she
will be thinking
how much she valued the man the prince
she fell in love with
so many years ago in almost 74 years
they were married
well indeed and catherine if we take a
look too at the guardian
you see just how handsome he was and who
would not uh fall in love with uh with
that young man and
still in his his later years um we see
him as a traditionalist don't we because
we hear about his
duty and his service but in many
respects he was ahead of the game wasn't
he his fascination with
so many different things a breadth of
knowledge and interests
yes everyone um always comments on how
well ready he was how
curious he was about technology and
um sort of and computers and how he
introduced sort of
walkabouts and wanted to bring the
cameras into the coronation
there's this idea of him
as a sort of old-fashioned sort of
benevolent uncle type but far from it
in his youth and later